don't come with the expectation that
you're going to pass the first try
reframe your mind to treat the first try
as a starting point hello everybody
my name is nayan i'm the black female
engineer i provide content for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we're going to be talking about
the flat iron school
coding challenges in flat iron school
which is the coding boot camp
i went to every about three to four
weeks there would be
a coding challenge kind of like a mini
project slash exam to test how well
you've picked up the material they've
taught in the last three to four weeks
and this it's it's not a fun experience
it's not a fun experience because you
get for me i got about
i think it was four tries total over
four days
if over those four days i ended up never
passing the you know coding challenge i
would be
in essence held back from continuing
on to the next module now if all of
these words just don't make sense
i'll link some more videos of mine below
where i talk about
coding boot camp and the flat school
process
in terms of what you expect and what are
modules and how is it broken up and all
of that so just check that out to
answer some of those questions but yes
it would prevent you from going on to
the next
module really being held back about six
weeks
so passing these coding challenges was
quite pertinent
to keep on with your timeline and just i
don't know keep a little bit of your
sanity throughout all of this so i'm
going to be providing you all with some
tips as to
how to pass them and the easiest way to
go about them
to just yeah maintain maintain that
level of sanity of yours
so let's get to it odds are when you do
get your coding challenge it's going to
be different from your
typical idea of an exam you won't have a
step-by-step guide of
okay make an if statement and then if
you pass that then you go and try the
next question of
okay now create an on click [__]
function and you go on to the next
it really or at least maybe by the tail
end of your time at coding bootcamp
it'll be more like hey we want you to
create this type of
app that has these functionalities
do it so prepare yourself for that so
i'm going to provide you all with an
example that i'm going to just carry out
through this entire video
so let's use the example of making a
calculator the coding challenge you're
given is
hey you need to make a functioning
calculator that allows the user
to add numbers as well as multiply
divide etc
and also clear out numbers without
deleting all previous work so clear
out a number if they made a mistake and
easily choose the right number
so build something like that and they
may add different details like the
calculator
must go plus minus divide multiply in
that order
and yeah things like that and that's
what i mean when i say it doesn't have a
step-by-step
guide it's more of an overall prod mini
project
that gives you the specifications
and says what you need to be able to
have accomplished or
what that app needs to be able to do and
so number one
start with what you know start with what
you know
don't just start coding right away you
need to take a second
to take note of what is being asked of
you and when i say take note i quite
literally mean
get a pen and paper out put that
computer to the side and take your notes
what is the overall goal of this coding
challenge
and what is being asked of you what has
been given to you have they
given you every file needed or will you
be needing to
create some yourself and all of that
figure out what are the core
deliverables
in the calculator example we say it must
be able to do
one two three four all the functions
must be
let's say on the right side the user
must be able to
clear out a mistake without clearing out
their entire backlog
of calculations they had been doing
write those down what is being
asked and what is expected for you to
produce
if there's an extra credit portion
ignore it ignore it right away we're not
even trying we're just trying to pass
don't waste any time on reading that and
trying to figure out how to solve that
when you haven't even
solved the bare minimum that they asked
for you typically
i'm trying to remember how long the
coding challenges were for me
you're not going to like my answer it
was either like
one and a half or three hours
was it four hours yo i don't remember i
don't remember
but it basically was an amount of time
that seemed absurd in terms of
like a long amount of time yet
every time i would look up and be like
oh my gosh i thought five minutes have
gone by and really i only have five
minutes left
so it was a lot of time seemingly to
like a couple of hours
when but don't let that fool you don't
let that make you think you can slack
off because that time will go
gone gone in just a few blinks so make
sure you're being diligent throughout
the entire
challenge okay so you've written down
what you know what's being asked of you
what your core deliverables are now
start working in thin vertical slices
now what are thin vertical slices thin
vertical slices basically means you're
taking this whole
problem and taking tiny the smallest
tiny bites
you can before trying to get through
this whole big thing
so the way you do this is you think to
yourself what is the most
basic most basic structure of this app
they're asking me to
build the tower of pisa okay what is the
most
basic structure i can give them okay put
on some
cardboard and glue it up and call it a
day so in the context of this calculator
app
it would be starting out with just like
let's say two buttons a one and a two or
a red button and a blue button
and having functions that say okay when
the
one is clicked console.log one
when two is clicked console.log two
now if that person clicks it and that is
actually
what the output is then you know you're
on the right direction
so then the next step would be okay now
let me add some type of operators
let me add a plus sign so when one plus
two is clicked
actually take those values and add them
and so just starting with like now
three buttons and so that's what working
pin vertical slices
is making sure that you are on track
making sure that
you are not biting off more than you can
chew right off the bat
trying to solve this huge make this huge
app to build the tower of pisa meanwhile
you're not even sure
if your on click functions work so i
know i'm talking a lot so let me remind
you of the first two things you do
step number one figure out what your
core deliverables are actually sit down
and
write those things out number two once
you find those things out
work in thin vertical slices to tackle
each of these things so number three
is don't go too long without rereading
what they gave you rereading the
worksheet rereading the
github readme or whatever that they gave
you to
solve this problem to solve this
challenge re-read that
and you don't have to be stuck to
re-read something the reason i say
re-read is because you will think
that you have the problems spits back
done
and then you look back and you're like
oh my gosh i
either totally missed a detail totally
missed something
and i just spent the last three hours
doing this that in the third and now i
have to
figure out to a way to add this
component to it
or two not even missing something but
you completely misread the problem this
has happened
to me i complete i was like okay bet
like
say no more and then it's time to submit
i'm like oh my gosh i completely
misread what they asked me to do
especially with coding is so
easy and like that's actually one of the
reasons i love development so much is
because it's so easy to just
go off into your own world and do your
own thing but
we're trying to pass so that this is not
the time to do that
so make sure you are not going too long
without rereading what was given to you
to make sure
you are on the right track and staying
on the right track number four
if you get stuck on things keep note of
what you're getting stuck on again
literally take your pen and paper and
write it down what exactly are you
getting stuck on is it
the on click function is it this
specific adding components and react
what
is it you're getting stuck on and the
reason this is so important
so i mentioned that we had about four
tries total for each coding challenge so
that was appreciated
very much so so pro tip try number one
don't go into it like bet i'm gonna get
it the first try
like don't even come at me like in five
minutes
teacher check your ip no don't come with
the expectation
that you're going to pass the first try
i'm not saying you won't i'm not saying
you won't
but reframe your mind to treat the first
try
as a starting point to treat it as
a way to see where the gaps in your
knowledge are because again these coding
challenges
are directly correlated to what has been
taught to you
the current challenges i got even would
be literally
what was something that was done during
a lesson so
during a lesson and so if i had just you
know made sure
i took notes and did building burns and
things like that
i would have gotten this code challenge
right away but of course with how
quickly coding boot camp goes and how
much information is being thrown at you
things slip through the cracks they do
and so
treat trial number one as a way to see
what has fallen through that crack and
so when you get stuck on something take
note of it don't panic don't be looking
at the time
stressing out take note of it so that
way when
you don't pass this first try
again i i don't think i ever yeah
i never passed on my first try so like
if that makes you feel any better take
that
because i never one of them actually
used up all my tries like was
went to the fourth try trembling hoping
i would they would pass
me and everything and so treat that
first try as a way to see where i
slipped through the cracks
where the gaps in your knowledge are and
when you submit it right away
go to that piece of paper where you
listed out where you're getting stuck
and now work on those is it on click
functions in javascript and vanilla
javascript okay
so now go and figure that out do
building birds practice
look up resources talk to your teachers
and your instructors and your classmates
y'all
i'll say this to one of y'all if you're
watching this like
sometimes it was not even my teachers
not even outside resources it was my
classmates
dragging me through that finish line
because
y'all it's a hard program it's intense
it's stressful and you can't do it alone
maybe you can but you shouldn't it's
it's you shouldn't because then
you're missing out on opportunities to
get closer with one another to help each
other out and
all of that so go to your classmates go
to all these different resources
and say hey i have trouble with on click
functions i have trouble
with x y and z is anyone available to
help me out with them
all of my you know lectures and sessions
with teachers
were recorded so i was always able to go
back to them so if
that is the same case for you go back to
those recorded lectures go back to those
recorded sessions
and code along make sure you're really
following along to take notes do
everything you need to do to make sure
you're crossing off that list
of things you got stuck on so when trial
two comes the day after or two days
after
you got it you got it because for me
it was always also the same the same
prompt the same
deliverables being asked the same exact
problem so
i was able to now go in the second or
third day
like not even needing to read it read it
but not even needing to read it because
i was like bet like i have it down i can
do this with my eyes closed so like
bring it on and my last tip for you all
i saved it for the last because i didn't
want y'all to
to roll your eyes when i said it as the
first thing
but read the question read the questions
so
and if you knew how many times
i don't read questions to things not
even like coding boot camp but even
exams
i don't read full questions i just
always
i think it's because i just get so
anxious and and like okay like
i have to i have to go quickly i have to
go now i have no time da da da
and so i just read the first few words
and then like my eye
jumps to like a key word and i'm like
cool bet and then i go
and then meanwhile i missed like the
not like the do not do this part and i'm
thinking and i'm over here doing it
so read the full questions a lot of
times
little hints will be scattered within
the
challenge they give you of ways to go
about the problems
little keywords indicating okay so i
actually should do
this first and then i actually will do
this next and i actually
can't do this without looking here so
really read it don't seriously
development and being just a software
developer
in the actual field is more than just
coding coding people
will tell you left and right it
sometimes is like 10
of the job seriously seriously you need
to learn to read
and really decipher the challenge
brought to you
before just jumping into code because
that kind of
what ends up making the difference
between a coder and a developer
so just keep that in mind also note that
each coding challenge
was kind of done a different way and so
the one
so i'm really sharing tips on more the
like hardest one i got
because i want to say i think maybe my
first coding challenge
it was more of like maybe
maybe a more step-by-step situation
where i was like make sure you do
this type of function and make sure
after you do that functioning do this
maybe that was like the first coding
challenge
the maybe yeah first or first two but by
you know
three four and five it was like yo we're
looking for a calculator app go
so keep that in mind so that
when you go to your first one you don't
think i lied to you so wait until you're
done and then
look back at this video and you'll be
like oh maybe maybe she was onto
something or maybe i wasn't if
you have tips of your own please please
please let us know y'all like let's
let's help each other so let me know put
in the comments but i hope this
helps at least one of you don't forget
to subscribe and like and comment
if you know you liked it it really helps
me and my channel a lot but again
thanks for watching and i'll see you
later bye